so the Doctor Who Twitter account has
been busy dropping a bunch of official
stuff we got a number of uh images for a
number of the actors I don't have that
much to say about these just because you
know it's still images what am I going
to say it is kind of cool to see God
will do you know like the handout thing
that Capaldi liked to do
um and as was noted by my thumbnail guy
Joel on Twitter I kind of like that they
have tenant marked as the 14th doctor
who got was just the doctor being nice
and definitive about it the bigger deal
for most people will probably be the
reveal of the Sonic Screwdriver which we
got a still image of it looks kind of
like uh 10 and 11 screwdrivers you know
had a baby of some kind but what I
really loved was the video reveal of
this thing which was shot like you'd
shoot the reveal of a new model of car
like for the people who like really are
into cars and like it Glides over the
components and like it's all shot and
Shadow and it's for the screwdriver like
whoever's currently handling the
marketing for Doctor Who they understand
this fandom they know what they're doing